[Musique]
mais avec nous pour en débattre mohamed
mechmache vous êtes le porte parole de
l'association ac le feu associations
collectif liberté égalité fraternité
ensemble unis un collectif on le
rappelle qui a vu le jour à clichy sous
bois au lendemain des émeutes urbaines
de 2005 à vos côtés gaëtan du sausset
vous êtes membre vous du conseil du
rassemblement national est également
délégué départemental du fn dans le val
de marne bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'avoir accepté ce face à face
je me tourne vers vous pour commencer un
gaëtan du dossier puisque c'est dans
votre département hier un qui a eu lieu
cette dernière x ultra violente deux
adolescents je le rappelle ont été
grièvement blessés au cours de cette
bagarre qui a eu lieu en plein jour et
en plein centre-ville l'un des deux est
d'ailleurs à entre la vie et la mort
alors question la bande les bandes
aujourd'hui sont-elles hors de contrôle
gaëtan à du sausset mais ce qui est
certain si vous voulez c'est que les
bandes
malheureusement ont quasiment pris le
contrôle d'un certain nombre de
quartiers et aujourd'hui rythme par leur
incivilité par leur agression et par
leur conflit entre bandes le quotidien
d'un grand nombre de français et en
particulier de franciliens vous l'avez
rappelé d'ailleurs dans l'est dans les
titres juste avant que nous commencions
ce débat il y a eu en 2020 quasiment une
rixe entre bandes quotidienne quasiment
une par jour c'est énorme et se rendre
compte que le gouvernement attend
finalement que ce phénomène devienne un
phénomène médiatique a fait mais un
phénomène dont on parle dans les médias
dans la presse etc pour enfin se décider
à faire quelque chose je trouve ça
regrettable parce que malheureusement
c'est quelque chose qui est quotidien
dans un grand nombre de quartiers et que
l'on connaît depuis bien longtemps
depuis bien trop longtemps et qui ont
plus de ça ne le fait que de s'aggraver
qui ne fait que de s'envenimer
donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
réponse terme 1 à voir et évidemment la
première des réponses n'est pas une
réponse sociale c'est avant tout une
réponse d'autorité une réponse d'ordre
il faut remettre de l'ordre dans ces
quartiers et ça fera évidemment d'abord
les habitants de ces quartiers qui sont
les premières victimes il faut le
rappeler de ces taxes et à l'insécurité
qui est devenu quotidien me ramène un
mec match une réponse ferme du
gouvernement on imagine
c'est pas nécessairement ce que vous
attendez non nous chassons continuera à
parler de cette jeunesse comme le fait
effectivement votre invité en expliquant
encore une fois que ces jeunes sont des
jeunes qui clairement sont totalement
perdus
moi ce que je trouve dommage ça fait
très longtemps qu'on ne le dit pas cette
jeunesse en tout cas qui vit
malheureusement pas très bien ce qui
n'excuse en rien de ma part les faits de
violence et bien au contraire je les
condamne c'est qu'il faudrait peut-être
qu'on lui dise qu'on le même un peu
cette jeunesse de cette jeunesse qui est
quand même désoeuvrés qui depuis très
longtemps et notamment dans ces
territoires
on a essayé de répondre que par une
forme de répression alors que ce qu'il
faudrait tout simplement c'est de
remettre quand même de l'humain dans ces
endroits faire en sorte que en gros la
présence d'adultes puisse est bien
présente qu' on puisse retrouver une
police de proximité qu'on puisse tout
simplement permettent à cette jeunesse
qui est quand même ce qui est dramatique
en fait c'est que j'entends ce que votre
ami teddy mais pas un brin sentiment en
tout cas qui est inquiétant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette jeunesse qui est
quand même pour certains en tout cas
qu'ils vivent notamment dans ces
territoires là c'est à peu près six
millions d'habitants une majorité c'est
des jeunes
donc c'est quand même l'avenir on ne
s'inquiète pas qu'aujourd'hui cette
jeunesse elle est capable de sauter la
vie sont se rende compte de ce qu'elles
sont en train de faire comme mal et et
surtout je suis inquiet de me dire que
en gros ils ont tout l'avenir devant eux
et en fait leur avenir ils s'arrêtent à
14 ans quoi donc c'est quand même
dramatique alors moi je comprends encore
une fois que ce qui est en train de se
passer on va essayer effectivement de
politiser en expliquant tunnel en
sécurité ont ainsi de suite on n'a pas
du tout envie de prendre en compte
honnêtement tout ce qui se passe à
travers ce qu'on est en train de vivre
actuellement c'est à dire que là on a
train de juste traiter les conséquences
les phénomènes de berne ça existe depuis
très longtemps on oublie qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya des réseaux
sociaux qui sont là il ya aujourd'hui
des jeux vidéos qui sont de plus en plus
violent où on a le sentiment encore une
fois que certains ont l'impression
qu'ils sont en train de vivre une
fiction moi je suis très
très inquiets les demandes de la
tournure que ça prend à l'époque les
personnes seront donnés rendez vous
effectivement ça existe et c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui je veux dire et puisqu'il
faut se dire aucun poids c'est que ça ne
touche plus que les quartiers ça touche
un peu y compris d'autres territoires
qui malheureusement sont aussi touchés
par ce phénomène de violence quoi donc
on pourra encore une fois comme votre
invité continue à expliquer en gros que
ça va être je sais très bien que sur
quoi on va dériver
je savais que la faute des milliers
d'émigrants un site unique aujourd'hui
cette violence allait générer
culturellement parce par des habitants
qui aujourd'hui ne respectent pas la loi
de la république
c'est totalement faux voilà c'est juste
dommage de le préciser parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de villes déjà deux provinces
qui voilà qui nous disent on va parler
nous aussi parce que ce genre de
phénomène en lieu en province alors il
se trouve qu en ile-de-france avec les
chiffres sont très impressionnants et il
ya eu malheureusement des morts ces
dernières semaines c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de l'île de france
je dois aussi précisé que ce soit il ya
une rixe aux abords du lycée jean de la
fontaine dans le 16ème arrondissement de
la capitale
ricks blessé quatre personnes sont
blessées à l'armé blanche sont en
urgence relative donc c'est pas que dans
les quartiers effectivement vous parliez
mois m dames et slash dl d'huile de
l'humain gérald darmanin lui parle des
parents il les met en cause ses parents
il appelle à leurs responsabilités
écoutez c'était il y a quelques jours
déjà
la société n'est pas responsable de tout
et que les policiers les gendarmes les
maires ne peuvent pas faire à la place
des parents une autorité qui consiste à
ne pas sortir seul le soir quand on est
un jeune adolescent d'aller suivre des
études ou une formation professionnelle
de ne pas avoir ce qui était le cas des
béquilles des armes blanches des barres
de fer
je pense que on conviendra tous ensemble
ce n'est pas l'équipe naturel d'un
enfant de 13 ans de 14 ans dans la rue
est rappelé que les parents ont un
devoir d'autorité un devoir d'autorité
pour les parents vous partager l'opinion
du ministre de l'intérieur gaëtan du
sausset alors si vous voulez long de moi
l'idée de devenir la boc
de monsieur gérald darmanin d'autant
plus quand ce ministre ou bien le parti
auquel il a il a été membre et militant
est l'un des cadres pendant de
nombreuses années évidemment je pense
aux partis de droite les républicains ex
ump se sont opposés à demain telle
entreprise aux différents amendements et
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
depuis plus de dix ans maintenant par
les députés du rassemblement national
qui visait justement notamment celles à
cette proposition de bon sens qui
consiste à responsabiliser les parents
en supprimant une partie des aides
sociales parce qu'il y a en effet une
carence éducative qui est constaté et
qui sont parents de mineurs récidivistes
j'aimerais bien revenir sur ce qu'a dit
votre invité parce que si vous voulez on
nous donne l'impression que finalement
la réponse des politiques vis-à-vis de
ces quartiers a toujours été l'ordre ou
la demande de fermeté aux d'autorité
mais grand dieu bien au contraire ça
fait trente ans maintenant que tout ce
que vous avez dit monsieur on le répète
sans cesse à longueur de plateau de
gouvernement de questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée donc à
l'assemblée nationale etc
ça fait 30 ans qu'on tient ce discours
là celui qui consistait le discours de
vue du laxisme le discours de l'excusé
sociale permanente où on explique c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas suffisamment moyens
mais ce sont des milliards d'euros qui
ont été déversées dans ces quartiers-là
des milliards d'euros que n'ont pas vu
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'autres
territoires de la france comme les
territoires ruraux
mais si là-bas acidanthera un certain
nombre de quartiers dits quartiers
prioritaires ou autres les les bureaux
de poste ferme
si les médecins n'ose pas y aller et
cetera ce n'est pas pour une question de
moyens ce n'est pas une question de
désir médicale ou autre c'est une
question de sécurité puisque ces gens là
ne veulent pas y aller parce que quand
ils vont ils se font agresser c'est ça
la réalité et moi contrairement à vous
je ne fais pas d'amalgamé entre la
majorité des jeunes qui sont là bas et
la petite minorité qui représente même
pas 1% de la population de ces quartiers
qu'ils sont responsables des rites ce
qu'on a de manière quotidienne et de
l'insécurité de la délinquance
quotidienne
parce qu'en réalité les gens qui
émettent le trouble dans l'ordre public
c'est une minorité et celle là il faut
la neutraliser donc moi je ne confonds
pas les français d'origine immigrée qui
habitent dans ces quartiers les français
d'origine populaire qui habitent les
quartiers et qui sont au contraire les
premières victimes c'est le vague
d'insécurité insupportable mohamed
mechmache la réponse et puis aussi je
voudrais votre avis parce que vous
connaissez bien cette cette question le
rôle des parents s
ils n'ont plus de pouvoir les parents
ils sont impuissants
alors encore une fois c'est trop facile
de parler de démission responsabiliser
les parents
ce qu'il faut savoir encore entre ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien dans ces
territoires là dans ces quartiers c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de familles
monoparentales et qu'il faudrait savoir
c'est que en gros ces familles bah ouais
elles ont plusieurs enfants
par contre il faut quand même pouvoir
subvenir à ses besoins donc elles sont
malheureusement ces femmes deux à trois
boulots par jour elles font des ménages
complètement ont décalé alors quand on
explique qu'on vient de me dire qu' il
faudrait pénaliser ces familles par le
biais justement des aides qui peuvent
avoir de l'état pour les soutenir
justement au contraire pour essayer
d'avoir une forme de parentalité et de
continuer à garder le seul familiale
pendant que tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont en capacité de les accompagner
leurs enfants à l'école d'aller chercher
le butin faut savoir que c'est maman la
health en train de faire le ménage dans
leurs bureaux et que effectivement il ya
un décalage que ces mamans elles sont
aujourd'hui on va effectivement
dépassées par la situation sociale
qu'elles vivent donc c'est bien facile
encore une fois d'essayer de pointe et
des parents comme s'ils étaient des
missionnaires comme si tous ces parents
avaient envie que leurs gamins glisse
dans une forme de criminalité dans la
délinquance
je pense qu'encore une fois on il faut
qu'on mesure réellement ce qui se passe
réellement sur ces quartiers-là faut
qu'on arrête de se servir de ce
réservoir de coupables comme si c'était
la faute
constamment t personnes là qui clermont
n'ont pas choisi vous n'a pas décidé
comme votre invité en train encore nous
expliquer ça fait 30 ans qu'on a mis des
milliards dans ces quartiers faut juste
savoir que cet argent qui a été versé en
direction des quartiers n'a pas été en
direction des populations n'a pas été et
a été très mal fléché
c'est à dire qu'en gros on a estimé qu'
aucun soin d barça allait régler le
problème humain et social
chose qu'il est faux la question humaine
et sociale n'a pas été du tout régler on
nous a expliqué que on allait créer
dalli cité mais combien aujourd'hui de
mer qui sont censés respecter la loi sru
25% logements sociaux ne jouent pas le
jeu
je tenais combien de communes qui
aujourd'hui n'ont que 10 % de logements
sociaux alors c'est trop facile parce
que tous ces gens qui vivent dans ces
quartiers là on se connaissait encore
une fois de l'épopée lisez encore un peu
plus sous le seuil de pauvreté fait que
d'augmenter n'ont jamais choisi de se
retrouver tous au même endroit c'est à
dire qu'on gros c'est là où les plus
grosses difficultés s'accumulent en
termes d'éducation en termes de services
publics en termes effectivement deux le
désert sanitaire et alors qu'on vient
pas me faire croire que parce que c'est
de l'insécurité que les gens ne viennent
pas non c'est tout simplement
il ya tellement de pauvreté dans ces
territoires là que encore une fois c'est
clair que ceux qui ont tous ailleurs le
déciderons jamais de venir s'installer
dans ces quartiers là et encore moins
les entreprises qui encore une fois fut
un certain temps des sucres et les zones
franches où il était censé devenir tout
simplement pouvoir s'installer dans ces
quartiers étaient exonérés de charges
vous savez ce qu'on a vu arriver des
boîtes aux lettres et ils n'ont jamais
joué le jeu de former ou d'embaucher des
jeunes issus de ces quartiers
alors moi je comprends le candidat qui
aujourd'hui de l'extrême droite qui ont
encore une fois veulent surfer sur ces
questions là parce qu'on voit que nous
quant à une présence et de la sécurité
cette croissance par 2 démontre que je
voudrais faire avancer le débat excusez
moi c'est vrai que vous êtes de haies
etc il faut que je distribue la parole
or on va terminer avec cette proposition
des zahia pas que le fn valérie pécresse
président de la région ile-de-france qui
donne une idée aujourd'hui enfin n'est
pas très nouvelle non plus un art mais
la police municipale de toutes les
villes de plus de 10 mille habitants
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition assez rapidement s'il vous
plaît pour que vous puissiez terminer 30
secondes chacun s'il vous plaît gaëtan
dussault s'est encore une fois valérie
pécresse elle aussi elle a été au
gouvernement à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy n'ont absolument rien fait ce
moment là alors que l'insécurité est
déjà très importante ils ont même fait
pire que ça ils ont supprimé un certain
nombre de postes de policiers dont
aujourd'hui tout le monde regrette et
même les républicains le regret donc
encore une fois je tiens vraiment à
préciser que la priorité pour permettre
à l'ensemble de la population qui vit
dans ces quartiers difficiles
la priorité c'est de remettre les choses
en ordre et de faire respecter
l'autorité parce que
avoir des discours à nouveau très prisé
en ce moment sur l'émotion sur la corde
sensible et c'est moi je veux bien mais
moi aussi j'ai grandi dans une famille
monoparentale avec une mère qui ma mère
on était quatre gosses et avait juste
inférieure d'infirmier mais moi je peux
vous assurer que quand on réussit un
petit peu dans la vie et qu'on arrive à
s'en sortir un petit peu mieux la
première chose qu'on fait c'est de
quitter ces quartiers là c'est d'aller
dans des endroits plus préservé parce
qu'on n'a pas envie de faire grandir des
enfants on n'a pas envie d fonder un
foyer
donc arrêtons un peu l'angélisme il ya
énormément d'endroits où il ya aussi
énormément de pauvreté énormément de
difficulté mais on n'a pas les mêmes
problèmes de sécurité mais pour ça faut
neutraliser la minorité qui pose
problème mais ce match
concernant justement ce que c'est une
idée qui revient beaucoup dans la bouche
de votre contradicteur
c'est une minorité qu'est ce que vous
répondez et ça sera le mot de la fin
c'est vous pouvez bien sûr que si mais
bien sûr que c'est une minorité qui
aujourd'hui nuit à la majorité mais
encore une fois je le dis je continue à
le persil c'est la répression ne ne
répondra pas à ce qu'on est en train de
vivre actuellement
si on remet pas la question de la
prévention effectivement et y compris de
la sécurité mais avec une police qui
aujourd'hui soit aussi aux capacités
pour certains de pouvoir être exemplaire
fera en sorte que les relations pause
population s'améliore et encore une fois
je le répète donc on dira pas cette
jeunesse qu'on l'aiment et qu'elle ait
un avenir et qu'on continue
effectivement à la stigmatiser alalala
allume à lui parler et on l'espère en
expliquant qu'en gros il sont les jeunes
qui ne sont et qui n'ont pas d'avenir
croyez moi que on est passés avec des
problèmes on est juste en train de
compliquer et de le rend plus difficile
à nice municipale armée très rapidement
parce que vous n'avez pas répondu à la
question
non je réponds pour moi mais que ça ne
sera pas la seule
ça ne sera pas la poule hélas ça ne sera
pas la solution
une police armée ça ne réglera rien on
est encore une fois sur une forme de
répression
moi je préfère la police de proximité
qui sera capable idée a une capacité
d'aller dialoguer d'échanger et puis
quand il faut faire de la répression
qu'elle le fasse et personne ne lui dira
le contraire
mais encore une fois vous répondez et
madame pécresse ne répond que par des
réponses sécuritaires et ce ne sont pas
les solutions
merci en tout cas à tous les deux mois
mais de mechmech et gaëtan
du social et d'avoir été avec nous pour
ce face à face en direct sur rt france
merci à vous deux